Hey, everyone.  We're going to be taking a look at why employee interest might not align with firm interest.
Imagine this.  You run a chain of phone stores.
Your sales team earns $18 an hour, no matter what.
Some are trying, others, well, they're just getting through the day.
Sales are slipping.
Customers are also slipping through sales as well.
You start asking yourself, why aren't my employees trying harder?  It's not laziness.
It's a broken system.
They don't benefit when the company does.
And that's the real problem.
This situation is a textbook example of something called the principal agent problem.
When the person doing the work, that is the agent, doesn't share the same goals as the person paying for it, that is the principal.
This leads to what we call incentive conflict here.
What's best for the employee isn't necessarily what's best for the business.
And to manage that conflict, businesses often face agency costs.
These are costs of monitoring employees, offering bonuses, or fixing problems caused by misaligned incentives.
And lastly, there's asymmetric information.
When one party knows more than the other.
And that causes two major problems.
Adverse selection.
You hire someone who looks great on paper but coast once they're in, and moral hazard.
Once they're hired, they know they can slack off because their pay doesn't depend on performance.
Let's get back to the phone store.
Your team has no skin in the game.
Whether they sell five phones or none, the paycheck is the same.
This is where moral hazard creeps in.
When employees don't bear the consequences of poor performance, they also don't feel pressured to do more than the minimum.
There's no downside for slacking off, and there's no upside for going above and beyond.
The system quietly signals, don't bother, it won't matter.
And if you hired someone who looks sharp at the interview but under delivers on the floor, then that's adverse selection in action.
You attracted someone who was good at getting the job, not necessarily at doing the job.
Both of these problems, moral hazard and adverse selection, stem from misaligned incentives.
Employees have different goals than you do as the owner.
And without the right structure in place, those gaps grow wider.
So we need to identify the problem and properly align incentives.
We know that there may be suffering from some form of adverse selection or moral hazard.
So let's fix the problem.
Let's first start by aligning incentives.
Suppose our employees earn $18 an hour and work eight hours a day.
That's $144 for one day's work.
The issue is this may not align with the company's interest in selling phones.
Now let's add a commission of $50 a phone.
The same employee now has more motivation to sell phones.
With eight hours worked and five phones sold, the employee now earns $394 for the day.
Now they win when the company wins.
Next, we might have to look at setting measurable goals.
Not every sale tells the full story.
Sometimes the best employees aren't the ones closing the most.
They're the ones offering great service, upselling with care and earning glowing reviews.
So instead of just rewarding raw sales numbers, build a system that values customer satisfaction.
Upsell success, where the agent sells a more expensive product or adds additional items to the product purchase.
Follow up diligence, where the agent stays in contact with potential or recent customers.
And then consistent professionalism.
Now, when your goals reflect the full customer experience, you send a message.
We value how you sell, not just what you sell.
Let's move on to the last step.
We've set the incentives, but we also want to make sure that our employees are following through.
Here we're looking at transparency and monitoring.
You can't improve what you don't measure.
So let's make performance visible to both leadership and staff.
We're going to use some tools like mystery shoppers.
Conversion rate tracking.
This is where you measure the number of people who buy an item over how many people who actually walk into the store.
And then peer reviews or team based metrics.
When employees know they're being evaluated fairly and consistently, they're more likely to stay engaged, focused and aligned with the company goals.
Taken together, these steps don't just reduce agency cost.
They've replaced control with clarity and discipline with direction.
But we're not done.  We've aligned incentives and put in other metrics.
But there's a catch.
When you introduce performance pay such as commissions and bonuses, you're not just motivating employees, you, you're also shifting risk to them.
We have a good economy where we can sell a lot of phones and a bad economy where we don't sell as many phones.
In the good economy, we sell five phones and earn a commission of $250.
In the bad economy, we only sell two phones and earn a commission of $100.
This creates a hit to the employee's pay risk.
In this case, is the economy being good or bad playing a big role in compensation?
Even if they give it their all, their income now depends on things outside of their control.
The economy, foot traffic, competition.
The risk isn't free.
Here we know that more risk will require higher compensation.
So most solutions to moral hazard and adverse selection come with these trade offs.
We adopt incentive compensation only if its benefits, like employees working harder or smarter, outweigh its costs, like having to pay more to offset the risk.
We want to motivate better behavior and create extra value that outweighs the cost.
And we can measure that against two things.
First, status quo or flat pay.
Here we ask is this better than just keeping everyone at $18 an hour with no bonus?
And then the second measurable item, other possible solutions where we ask could we get the same improvement with less cost?
Maybe through better training, better hiring, team based rewards or non cash recognition.
But we don't have to choose between motivation and fairness.
There are ways to design smarter systems that manage the risk.
Here we can look at base and bonus pay, keep a steady paycheck, then reward strong performance on top.
This protects income while still driving effort.
We can offer team incentives, group rewards, reduce individual income swings and boost collaboration.
Look at profit sharing, let employees win with the company.
Long term alignment equals long term motivation.
And then lastly, look at minimum guarantees, set commission floor so even on slow days, income doesn't fall off a cliff.
Now, when we manage our risk smartly, incentive pay can do what it's supposed to do.
It can align behavior, boost performance and build loyalty without pushing our team over the edge of so here's the big idea.
People respond to the system you build.
It's not about good employees versus bad employees.
It's about what your structure rewards and what it ignores.
On the left we see what happens under bad incentives.  Flat pay.
No feedback, no recognitions.
Employees are disengaged, the store feels lifeless, customers are walking out and no one seems to care because the system doesn't ask them to.
On the right side, things look a little bit different.  There's energy.
Salespeople are present, helpful and motivated.
They're not just showing up, they're showing up to win.
And that's what happens when incentives and expectations are aligned.
Let's wrap this up with incentives that work, match rewards, reward what matters, not just what's easy to track.
Compensate fairly for risk.
If you're asking employees to carry uncertainty, pay them for it.
And then lastly, design with human behavior in mind.
Systems should work with people, not against them.
Incentives aren't just about money.
They're about motivation, trust and alignment.
Set the right structure.
One that's going to encourage ownership, effort and care.
Not because you're watching, but because people feel invested.
Set the right incentives.
Trust your people and support them with a system that works.
And that's all that we have.
Hope you've enjoyed it.